chris bines any pitcher i rinsed I'm
than hi I are going to give me a shot
this week as a real busy guys and we're
going to keep it down to half now so she
gets tied straight into any questions
how is yours Fe hello she get
strengthened moderator let's do yeah
we're going to focus primarily on the
moderator this week because we're down
to 30 minutes so anyone who spotted the
on Monday we put a post on plus android
developers saying bring it down make it
a bit more of a compact show and be more
of a guide to what's actually been going
on in the show afterwards as well yeah
we might be try and play the format
quite a bit as well so another game
through all of and recos questions
unless we crack on the one hand
moderator machines saw the post on
monday right field in and put like 20
questions yeah okay Crichton let's go
for it and so everland has asked all
developers will be able to reply to
comments on google play is so is there
an estimated date oh that is one of the
things we usually put in the publish a
hill it's on the show we won't be
announcing any road map things that
aren't you i was talking about but we
have not be said that the idea is to get
the reply to reviews out of everyone
we're just taking some time building the
features and things to support that from
tate i'm in a small intestine treatment
mode not that small okay next question
as you go from the top is there an api
to programmatically build a video frame
by frame I want to do this to be able to
screen capture point out so I can
convert what is happening on the screen
into a video uploaded to YouTube from
within the app and that's asked by neyo
in New York City no there's not an
official Android API for that I guess
you could do it you can grab ffmpeg or
something and put one together you could
have a look at using the media codec
classes to try and put one together but
it's so you wouldn't create a video
stream as an output you could upload on
youtube it's not optimized that there
you'd have to do like some kind of color
space conversions and all this done turn
it into a stream basically from the
bitmap yeah he'll be extremely
non-trivial the other men shall be going
to have is get natural screenshots
unnatural what if you roll up
it's gonna be slow every right yeah it's
not ideal so no not really no so an
alternative to this I've seen a bunch of
games especially who want to do this
kind of thing want to capture footage
and uploaded to youtube and what they
found easier is to almost capture the
info vent so like you know what these is
pressed and time codes more not and
upload that which is quite efficient to
a server and then almost like replay the
action and generate a video on the
server and from your server upload to
youtube so that's a plus blood eternity
I don't know from you from your
description of that work view but
because it mmm yeah it's good point
trying to video like a 25 30 frames a
second game as it's playing probably
have quite a impacts influence right now
how to the memory and then for 13 and
uploading it afterwards okay welcome to
your hair as well and well as one hey
guys thanks trainees hi guys oh hi I'm I
put one question on last minute very
last minute calm today sorry about that
just wondering about if you guys have
come across any browsers the due to way
ssl using the keychain have you heard of
anything like that no I know you seem
you mean for Android at least yes sorry
Android on the Android yeah on the
Android device in here on the Play Store
anyone know of no just have a quiz the
Play Store there aren't that many
high-end browsers and try them out um
but I've certainly not tested on any of
the browsers will seen it in a feature
list anyway all right kiss okay there's
nothing Matt smoke here you should get a
next muffin Matt sick today so I'm gonna
have to bench any google TV questions
till next week it's probably watching
get well soon that come on next one okay
so I read the next one so next question
says what is the current status of
application in jelly bean blogs reported
in August that it was disabled but
complete conflicting reports from users
and devs if min SDK is 16 as in android
4.1 and paid out this publish this month
will it be encrypted on all devices
I think yes was the answer last I heard
he did go live and in the worst of
issues so we kind of pulled it back out
played with it fixed and put it back in
again but that was all resolved months
and months and months ago as far as i
know the app encryption has been working
on jellybean for comfort for many months
now alrighty and is called paid
applications from the place book
qualified his question from why for and
it's a design type question so is it
fine to have a horizontally scrolling
views like a viewpager in a 30 scrolling
sort of scroll view only seen many apps
to do this and does his go against the
android design principles i think he's
talking about the kind of BBC news style
app tap too so that's where you have a
kind of list of horizontally scrolling
views and it's quite a good way of
laying out information on their android
device can you conflict through it both
ways with one hand so if you have topic
based information it could work but from
a design point of view yeah no role is
it that i guess to be careful that is it
easy to navigate you don't want to use
to feel lost any point to make sure
you've got enough you know highway signs
or whatever you want to call it that the
user knows exactly where they are i also
be careful of your finger tracking as
well making sure you're locking in one
direction is where i can get quite
annoying if you're trying to scroll down
and you have a slight movement one way
and it cancels their old start
describing another way so just make sure
that all that work coffee but from a
design point of your notes any problem
with it yeah i guess it gives you
ability to have infinity times something
not amount of data so just one into the
scrolling this you can have an infinite
number of them from a building lists
infinity times infinity so much more
later that's one next one okay say nany
in California asks after the end of any
key event review in Paul calls focused
search on the view which currently has
focused in the case of list view there
is no view at the top and bottom the
review will return a different view how
does lesser you handle the scenario um
I've looked at the list view source if
handling focus is quite tricky is called
complex so it's all in there so
specified giving it really and I've
don't know the intricacies of it
it's different fish implementation so
less fuel thrillingly linearly as it
goes down whereas gridview will do left
right and then like in a good view so
just have a look at the source and see
okay fricke mm-hmm but one of those
great things listen always just pop it
off by saying it's pretty readable looks
money so next question from Andrew Kelly
in Sydney when passing parameters to an
intent do you have any thoughts on why
some methods use arraylist EG put string
array list extra i always fought it as
bad practice to use an implementation
instead of an interface wanna put string
list extra and I don't look at source of
Andalus morning I couldn't see a reason
why they've done this I guess it's just
previously there was a performance and
penalty reviews interfaces and it might
also be that when you define the aidl
you have to define concrete types and
list isn't a concrete type that's true
yeah yeah that's probably ashley is your
alternate in to buy anything then yeah
nice good to have you back out it's a
pleasure oh yeah okay yep not everyone's
a different next one yeah chug again yep
audience Russo ones just popped up on
moderator as i was looking as erdis and
set asks if i have a progress dialog
showing in a fragment what I download
data how I removed the dialog if the
phone comes back from soft clothes how
can i prevent the dialogue from being
leaked hot soft clothes i was going to
say what you think it's soft like
missing hidden button does he mean on
pause on stop you forgot to stop I don't
agree how can i remove the dialogue if
the phone comes back from a soft close
as in the app is still in memory but
it's just being resumed again yeah all
that relaunching well then you'll get it
on your own resume you can either choose
on your own paws on your resume
mmm can you a reply zealous if you're
still here following along and with some
some clarification on what you're asking
I mean at the time when it returns from
soft clothes you should get some kind of
indication from the system that your app
has resumed probably on on with you
depending on quite what you mean by soft
clothes at that point you should check
if your download has finished if it has
finished of course just remove the
dialogue if it hasn't finished just
update it yeah good progress there might
be two if you do get your own paws to
dismiss the dialog itself and perhaps
for a notification if the download is
ongoing and then when they were in your
resume you can cancel an education
reshape I look like the nice way so you
never actually losing track it's always
one of the other referring to the
leaking section you'll never leak a
dialogue all that because it would
bounty activity so since the activity
goes your dialogue will so memory want
another leaking nice cool alright next
question live for these moderators today
so Andrew Katie's put another question
in the moderator because he hasn't so
once an intense service enters the on
handling tent method is there a way to
cancel the processing from an activity
he's after something like the cancer
method on async task we'd also accept
what grounds I don't mine is no death to
my intent service and no there's not
pretty much should I priority handling
is no ordering it is there is the order
in which you receive right it's supposed
to be a foreign forget type service so
you're not supposed to really care what
happens after you fired it yes very
somewhere in the loop you can build a
finishing or something work yeah you
want if you're saying lost bc i so I'm
like Robo spice I think dis that isn't
it errands have a look to that it's a
third-party library out there for doing
this kind of thing on your birthday
volume 00 hello who said that actually
contribution there's so it's probably
worse if we look at this level of detail
setting up like custom binder I'm
putting the code in that and then I'd
just having the main service loop look
for a setting that you're setting bar a
method in that binder yeah it'll pick it
up at some point and dump out
agree if you know that this is a case
that you're going to be frequently
coming across this many ways they're
doing it what is intense service
designed for long running tasks they
because I tended to only use it for sure
running things so it wouldn't really
have an activity that would last long
enough to need killing know exactly it's
if I forget so it's short short lifts
hassle it should just be fired on the
you want they want on another frayed and
see as you sir it should be short-lived
us I think Andy Andrews using it for him
as a rest client and oh yes but more the
first point energy you just seem to
round up night and ran out of time so
it's space I'd see if all about having a
global flag outside of the service with
the service checks went on handling temp
completes if the flag is set then
returns results is normal otherwise
discard the result this doesn't free up
any resources etc but just mean you
don't cancel they don't have worry about
didn't you i love you could there's a
property fish rest back end why doesn't
your implementation inside the internet
service check the flag average often as
well because of it knows it's not going
to need the result you can just kill it
some yeah stop processing I don't know
what's inside your um yeah definite ache
like a robust place it's definitely
built to do this kind of thing it's it
the actual implantation of intent
service is about 15 yards of code so
it's not silly complex if you want to
take it yourself then add add add to it
it's not difficult so that's probably
why I'd say to do okay when we've got a
full set of 10 people inside the hang
out with us today so even though we are
primarily focusing on the moderator
because we're in this reduced 30 minute
format which I think so for US forces to
answer more question her more questions
well concisely which was one of the
points does anybody who has joined us in
the Hangout have a question for us and
thank you for joining us in advance
somebody is typing Ali it's kind of a
trick question anybody else not heads
nodding at all all just here for the
experience Al's dumped out now I was
like didn't know about your question Jim
faster much where yeah I will got one no
questions at the moment okay oh yeah who
is that uh it's the one without dear
camera because i had done Kevin can you
hear me yeah we can't either Lee another
okay good so I'm developing this android
application and as part of me my
application I've got webview which is
used to display the guide of the
application the data comes from the
local application because it's
dynamically generated so I can't really
use a new web an external website my
question is I randomly I don't know how
to reproduce it seldom it happens get
white pages so the pages there the links
are dead the links actually work because
I if I click on the links i see that the
history of the world do changes and
stuff but it's completely white this if
it this only happens on Android for not
to on Android too I can't test on three
because I don't have any devices with
Android 33 sorry have you tried the
hardware acceleration in the webview
it's the first port of call for all
these kind of issues there sorry can you
repeat if you tried looking at the
hardware acceleration try the window I
dread having turned off there was a lot
of hardware acceleration optimizations
that have been going into the webview
through Android 3 and Android for no 4.1
4.2 and it sounds like a classic lack of
redraw on the hardware acceleration oh
it makes this mmm oh you could just drag
it in your manifest to turn in hardware
acceleration off uses hardware
acceleration falls if that works for you
then maybe
have a look at our blog posts on which
functions in a webview do support
hardware acceleration okay maybe you can
work around it i hope you don't have to
disable have our acceleration for the
whole web view for the whole time but
it's definitely the first thing to check
oh just interesting then there's
something I have had no idea about well
thank you I'll have a look at it thank
you very much no problem thank you for
the question alrighty 20 x 30 better my
written let's go for it so andrew kelly
again asks if I potion up in the samsung
or amazon store and not in google play
store do I risk run the risk of not
being able to use the newer google play
services api's EG maps or YouTube API
any expand I think if the user doesn't
have a Google Play account they can have
an out-of-date version of Google Play
api's or can these be updated on a
device without Google Play account what
if they have a google play but have
never signed in will the api's get
updated when you do new releases a few
maps um ok suppose from the model right
here I just let you go for it and so
Google Maps the APR is and distributed
for the google play services a peek a
key which is disputed on google play and
the you to die p is distributing youtube
app and so if the user those apps on
updated the necessary levels and the
user you will never be able to use this
API and so in short extra question if
they don't have google play on account
or they haven't signed in don't assume
you can use google api's one other
things about the amazon store as it
comes on the kindle fire which doesn't
have to play at all so they just won't
know available yeah so make sure you're
doing checking of services are available
before you start using them you're safe
for this publishing the Play Store if
you publish it in the other ones I just
be careful yeah there are a bunch of
services that are still available you
could use potentially the match the web
version of the Maps API instead of the
android client version there are there's
a YouTube Lenape as well I could use in
order to avoid
and then maybe fall back on that because
the Android native experience delivered
through the place was going to be better
for this they're not available use the
web api's next question is there a way
to query if the user has enabled a pin
password or face unlock for their device
I have an app that requires the user to
enter a pin but I could skip this step
if I trusted the Android device and
identity the user first say so yeah I
was looking the sorceress and in key
guards i thinkI got manager there's a
method called East keycard secure that's
the only real sort of method is exposed
to a developer that you can sort query
and and there's different level security
say for example and a pin or password is
because it's secure whereas a face
unlock isn't necessarily consider to
secure and these come down from the
device profile stuff so you know where
you can have activesync profiles and so
on which you know you can require the
app has to be secure you know enforced a
corporate device for example has a
sufficiently complex password they're
their definitions of what secure and
what's not secure so that's why we're
reverting absolutely oh just checking
the rush android-developers thread as
well there's a some comments going on
one cheeky one from vibha that I'm just
totally going to ignore I don't have an
answer for you for that vibha but there
you go um so I guess back unless anybody
in the Hangout has a question hi this
precise moderator prioritize moderator
there's more there's more like the road
is here Nolan next moderator question
okay so contour is all requests sink and
on perform sink and my abstract sync
adapter is completed fine but on my
device under settings / accounts the
indeterminate progress bar runs forever
and is the sink active returns truth
also the weight lock detector reports on
logcat yes I read this one and I'm
guessing referring to abstract Freddy to
sync it up rocks are definitely risen
abstract single other and so I mean this
cream multiple reasons what this happens
the fact that you mention a white clock
is ring alarm bells as you must about
that yourself and so
but I mean that there are samples
available on the android developer
android com which sort of go through all
this so I'd go through that and make
sure your code is sort of roughly
similar and Seaver doing anything weird
or funky which made calls and frayed to
keep running or anything all that and so
this is the cookie millions of reasons
why this could happen yep we've received
a message in the chat as well for a
month from Marty hey Marty are there any
special permissions required for reading
a file from the SDK they're used to not
be any permissions required for reading
file from the SD card but as a jelly
bean you do need now the real external
storage permission just to be fair yeah
it's optional women so we we are at some
point going forces permission right now
a user can if they're in a little divert
the settings go on and make it a strict
mission but right now it's kind of an
advisory one if you target API 16 and
you're rich with short storage you get
al in terror at nit area I got an indoor
Neely's telling you that you should be
requesting the read external storage
permission and as a Hugo points out you
definitely need the right external
storage permission if you're going to be
writing to the SD card thanks guys oh
that canal question yeah how does that
we go go ahead last night I have an
fragment with an inline asynctask that
show a progress dialog when the
asynctask start okay i am rotation i
like to know what is the best and
working solution to keep on the screen
at the progress dialog your death i say
you're going to lose your racing task
when you rotate the easiest way the way
i would normally do is either not user
nating task or go stop the on
configuration change for rotation and
and relay out yourself if you just allow
the system to to perform its rotation
it's going to relay out you're going to
lose your racing task and then
and your dialogue as well so you have to
control the rotation through the
manifest yeah either don't use async
task for it yes I know that an inline
async task is very quick and easy to
throw in but you could have a separate
thread and a handle F to pass the
messages back in which case you control
that yourself it's not too many more
lines of code or stop the rotation the
whole configuration change going through
the rotation no dessert just stop the
rotation need so not my case I would
like just that when I rotate to the
phone for the progress dialog Jesus
these desk yeah so I don't mean stop the
rotation has enforced the application to
stay in one orientation I mean when the
rotation happens a non configuration
change message is passed into your
application or you can request one in
the manifest and at that point you can
request that the the layout is relayed
out and this work also for fragments or
work on the underdog DD yeah you can
work for fragments as well and if you
don't let the system follow through sun
um life cycle for rotation then it won't
kill your racing task thank you very
much yeah it's the way that things like
a YouTube application do it when they
want to rotate and keep the video
playing ok ok cool as a couple of
questions that you and Andrew can't even
have your back off of chat with you know
I mean how does computers get into
consciousness started killing you ok so
Leon it in Israel asks I want to use a
content provider with the content
resolver bulk insert does he have some
kind of cue or how it works when there
is many inserts any comment on that
cruise I can't sell of the source of
that and I guess the book and so yeah
you basically build up a list of content
operations right yeah and then yeah it
will basically loop over them so they're
keeping to do there is really make sure
your yielding in the
yeah if you're doing database if you're
a sentence of database make sure each
transactions till you'll get performance
increase it not naturally says and yes a
really about that there's any concern
about it's worth making a blocker code
inside the bulk insert better or rather
in the insert method synchronized now
that force single threaded one job at a
time on the inserts hmm but i think it
probably there is a mob you know
advantages of having one call to bulk
insert rather than you know you know in
a loop perhaps calling in said not many
times we can be doing lots less IPC and
stuff I'd say build them up and Bob
conservatives a good idea cool the reign
of health in Germany currently asks is a
possibility to show an animation by
redrawing the same activity with
different data using a gesture like a
fling for example to zoom out into a
monthly overview or zoom into a weekly
would be better to create two activities
thanks so drawing the same motives are
different okay so it sounds like you
want to look at something called the
activity options part which will do that
for you for the zooming in case at least
you won't get the zooming out but yeah
but say you wanting to open from a small
thumbnail into activity then you look at
the recent animation which rich is
beautifully demonstrating that no one
can see on their phone come on tipping
work on later on I don't want to be on
video huh text but this is actually part
of the animation framework now do you
have to do this kind of I'll stop doing
that oh yeah it's gonna be quite tricky
if you do yourself an issue going to go
into all the overriding pending transit
transact transitions of stuff like that
yeah unless you do its fragments and
then do is my emotions s-curve
energy and so that's because the
fragment transaction will give you a way
to add animations to the actual
transaction so I handle that for you so
that's when we good were then you won't
go to animate the whole chrome with the
window right you wouldn't be doing the
action bar anything it's just going to
the contents with it yeah yeah two
things need to take a look at their that
helps just follow of sentence on
developer.android.com the content
providers methods
may be called from multiple threads and
so must be implemented in a thread safe
manner it's probably back to the last
question yeah cool good Sharu in india
says can we suggest nap improving the
signal strength of Xperia mini no we
can't no not merely apps for
improvements in your face on the device
yet there's probably some for faking the
signal strength not from proving it and
also Nuria development ok so we go to
come here we achieve our answer but
we're going to read them out for the
prosperity sake and we got you up to 10
half minutes ok so with the google play
a private channel how does this work for
apps i want to release internally in
beta and a nap someone to publish on
google face off everyone can i choose a
target audience each app and so when you
publish apps to your private channel
their only accessible to people in your
organization your domain yet and and so
it took to you under what channel you
actually publish your apps to so if you
weren't published that BTW to your
company then it up you have two pups you
twice and the last question for
moderator in the 14 hundred cases from
within an app can i programmatically
work out which app store it was
downloaded from or do i need to have a
separate code base for each store with
different features involve etfs building
an app though sponsored by samsung and
so package managers got a good method
for this called get installer package
full package remember all it was not
that where you give it a package name
with you gamestop name okay and it will
give you the package name with installer
so be that google play or Amazon or
wherever and or not if the user install
it manually and fear that's probably
best by doing that okay done with the
monitor or more popular sorting leave or
whilst makes funny that i will say that
um today man excellent ah if you happen
to be in London tomorrow night we're
going to be hanging out at the london
android usergroup over its gills matter
yeah niall tree all three thanks thing
so we'll be discussing storm david
chandler from our team in the US is
coming over
so discuss st 0 RN the london android
usergroup tomorrow night so if you
happen to be around london please pop in
and say hello well sign up at meetup com
full / android first of all so hope you
enjoyed the new compressed format and as
we said we're going to be giving
priority to the moderator so it readers
encourage you to get your questions in
earlier which gives us more time to give
you a better than plants hopefully so
see you've got through as much material
in this half hour usually doing an hour
to endless let's chat so you come for
the chat I'm sorry put it in the
moderator I'm well discuss it okay
thanks very much everyone catch you
again next week just guys thanks guys hi